un filtre on peut se voir comme quand on
est des jeunes je vous montre j'ai
jamais ressemble à ça de ma vie
j'ai l'impression que je fais du rugby
je m'appelle je suis pas
ça meule
qu'est-ce que non en fait c'est bien de
vieillir je suis content j'aime bien mes
pieds je vous jure
il y a 95 kg là qui sont
plus où il est là
ça fait un petit moment
j'ai décidé de pas me raser tant que je
serai immobile voilà peut-être que je
vais devenir le capitaine Haddock et
vous donner des nouvelles voilà
maintenant trois semaines quasiment jour
pour jour 3 semaines et deux jours 20 25
jours que j'ai été opéré je n'ai plus
aucune douleur oh là là
[Musique]
quelle est la personne la plus connectée
dans tes contacts Jean Dujardin si j'ai
demandé de l'Afrique ou pas appeler Jean
Dujardin là
Jean Dujardin il est quelle heure là il
est tard il est minuit il va être chez
lui il va dire qu'est-ce qu'il veut
Bigflo je le ferai pas je vois où tu
veux m'emmener là
n'importe quoi ça si vous avez le numéro
de quelqu'un de connu même des gens pas
reconnu ne les appelaient pas c'est toi
qui fait le concept abonne-toi n'écoute
pas les gens qui te disent qu'il ne faut
pas faire ce qu'il ne faut pas faire les
gens qui disent quoi qu'il ne faut pas
faire ce qu'il ne faut pas faire la
personne m'a dit ça alors ne les écoute
pas mais du coup faut faire quoi si tu
veux jouer dans la boue joue tu es
descendu dehors sous la pluie juste pour
faire cette vidéo si tu veux danser tu
peux danser je sais pas danser quand je
danse on dirait que je vends des actions
à Wall Street si tu veux être ridicule
soit le ah bah c'est l'histoire de ma
vie
bonjour c'est Serge hier après-midi
et là je suis tombé amoureux une jeune
femme c'est installée à côté de moi
commander un café crème sans sucre
et je l'observais elle restait
tranquille
sans m'adresser un seul regard